everybody is Charlie huge news they just
confirmed the entire royal family for
the inhuman show including lockjaw so
let's break this down the huge news is
they cast the entire royal family for
the Inhumans TV show including lockjaw
that's right they are doing locked on
the TV show people probably would have
rioted if they didn't so what I'm going
to do is explain what's going on what
each of their powers are and where this
takes place in the Marvel Universe
because they've revealed the time in the
setting so it's all in there with
infinity war and the rest of the series
so it's all really good news so there's
a new round of the spider-man giveaway
I'm giving away those action figures all
you have to do to enter is be a
subscriber leave a comment on this video
while we freaked out about Inhumans
stuff so here's the deal they started
shooting the TV show in Hawaii today
literally as I'm posting this video so
that's why they announced all these
actors I know you guys have a lot of
questions about what this has to do with
Inhumans on agents of shield because
that's said in present day that ties in
with the movies this is part of the
Marvel Universe
it'll also tie in with the movies so
what does that mean for shield -
Inhumans they haven't said anything
other than it's not a shield crossover
so there isn't any intention right now
to cross characters over so they Loki
might just be ignoring everything that
agents of shield has done but that
doesn't mean that they'll never have
crossover characters Phil Coulson is
always like the go-to guy for crossing
over if he's mr. shield and wouldn't he
be interested in a mystery inhuman city
that just popped up out of nowhere on
the far side of the Moon those seem more
like questions that they'll hold off for
comic-con when they start dropping
trailers and then just open the door
later on for potential crossover because
I think the shield might only get like
one more season so it's only going to be
an issue for a little while longer but
because it's only eight episodes it
sounds like it'll be relatively
self-contained so I wouldn't expect any
agents of shield stuff happening at
least during the first season the last
big time the royal family was featured
on TV was during the first season of
that guardians of the galaxy cartoon
there was a stop okay sit right next to
field and he was cute
later than that one I am magnimous the
man with this scent supreme leader of
the Inhumans okay what then in human
many thousands of years ago on a planet
called Earth
the Korea experimented on a tribe of
prehistoric humans these experimental in
humans became hyperevolved genetically
superior they were feared and hated by
their primitive brethren and forced to
live in seclusion
those were my aunt Esther who built this
marvelous city mashallah
it was then that they discovered the
Terrigen crystal in the caverns beneath
the city exposure to the crystals gave
us each unique and amazing powers but
the hair thing like the hair thing
my husband's power is in his voice that
is why he dared not speak even the
slightest whisper to level a city
we've trained all his life to remain
silent but the antenna helps to focus
his energy if it were damaged then say
hello to employees so we have Black Bolt
Medusa Karnak Gorgon triton crystal
lockjaw and Maximus the mad the entire
Corps royal family so what's going to
happen is is season one is going to be a
Black Bolt origin story like the rise of
Black Bolt but there's another mystery
characters that they haven't named yet
who's working at this aerospace firm who
has a passion for all things lunar so I
think that's the hat tip for her a
normal person working on earth
discovering that add to land exists and
then learning about the existence of the
Inhumans in that being sort of the entry
point for the audience she sort of like
the audience surrogate for it's like oh
my god
I'm in this crazy space Game of Thrones
universe what's going on there's always
a character like that in all new TV
shows so she's going to be the one who's
like what is the deal with your
teleporting dog bear could you please
explain that to me
and that's just an easy way for the TV
show writers to explain the really crazy
comic book concepts to people that don't
read comic books but all the things so
the Hat tip here the thing that kind of
places this in the timeline is the fact
that this mystery character works in
aerospace so that means that it's in
modern day which means it's closer to
infinity war so a lot of people were
wondering if it's going to be a prequel
how far back in the past is it set it
sounds like it's relatively contemporary
they haven't exactly set a date so I
couldn't tell you that it's right after
the first Iron Man movie or it picks up
the events right after Captain America
Civil War we don't know that much
information yet
they'll probably reveal more information
as people start doing interviews as
they're shooting the series it's about
eight episodes I think it's only
supposed to be eight episodes because
they're calling it a miniseries and
that's why they're able to spend so much
more money on it like it's really
expensive to do a teleporting dog in
every single episode so you have to
imagine that if they're going to do core
Royal Family and they want to do a
really amazing job of visualizing that
so that requires a lot of special
effects which means a really huge budget
so imagine how much money they spend on
agents of shield double that number then
cut the episodes more than in half and
then imagine what that might end up
looking like on screen so they're really
going all out like a bee
she is really bringing their big guns to
bear powers and abilities though you
guys all know about Black Bolt sonic
scream but really what's going on is
that he's harnessing this weird
electrical interaction that enables him
to create this electromagnetic field and
that's part of what forms his scream but
he can also use that ability to fly he
can use it to strengthen himself create
shields he can do all kinds of stuff
with it but even without that the
Terrigen myths have enhanced his
physique so that he's someone like
Captain America or Black Panther who was
just a really big badass even without
extra special abilities in addition to
that he also shares a low-level psychic
bond with other members of the royal
family and people of his blood his
brother Maximus the mat has a lot of
brain oriented abilities he has psychic
powers he can take control of other
people's minds he's a genius on the
level of Reed Richards so he just
someone who delights in tormenting
people scheming plotting just messing
with people's heads
so Ramsay Bolton from Game of Thrones is
going to be having himself a a lot of
fun black both wife has the crazy hair
they can do all kinds of stuff so what
it is is that each of the strands of her
hair has the tensile strength of steel
and she controls it psionically so she
can use it to take control of people she
can move it around however she wants so
she can use her hair to attack people to
trap them to do just whatever she wants
to do we don't know if she's going to be
married to Black Bolt when the series
picks up but she is the main love
interest so if they aren't married then
they probably will be by the end of the
series black both chief adviser karnak
is going to be so much fun so you know
about his martial arts abilities but his
real power is in sensing the faults in
everything so there's this really
awesome panel during civil war 2 where
the Inhumans want to take down Tony
Stark so Karnak walks up to the stark
tech building and he knows the exact
place to hit the building that will
bring it all crashing down with a single
blow so in a practical way in a
metaphorical way he's able to see the
weaknesses in all things and sometimes
that comes in handy and fights sometimes
that comes in with planning Gorgon has
the ability to generate seismic blasts
and waves with these giant legs and
hooves
he's also Black Bolt general so he's
this really high
hedid military man who's all about
charging into battle whereas karnak is
sort of the master planner he's the
other side of the equation that really
tries to think his plans through Gorgon
is more of a Hulk type character smash
first ask questions later
Triton as you can expect from his name
his appearance is sort of the Aquaman of
the group he has a lot of aquatic based
abilities so underwater he's boss
crystal is Medusa's sister she's the
baby of the group she has the ability to
control the elements and then you know
all about lockjaw
he has infinite ma which is matter
ingestion he can eat and consume
anything that is a funny joke about him
being a dog I guess whenever he was
created by Jack Kirby and Stanley Oh
dogs will eat anything
so lockjaw will literally eat anything
he can teleport across space-time he
also has precognition and I am so happy
that he's going to be on the show but
he's about 2,000 pounds so he is like a
horse sized dog
then there's Orand who's the leader of
the Royal Guard who has a really weird
ability is called parabolic hearing so
she can pick a word and if anybody
anywhere within a certain radius says
that word it will let her know like she
detects it because of that she's also
chief investigator so when she's on a
case she can pick a keyword in Google
Alerts style it'll ping her mind
whenever somebody says the word so
that's really all we know about the
series so far takes place relatively in
present-day
we know that because of the teaser for
that mystery character that at land will
probably be on the far side of the Moon
like it was originally in the comics it
moves around like they can actually move
the city but usually it's cloaked from
view and it sounds like the royal family
has been living in at land this whole
time it's not like they've grown up
somewhere else and then they'll travel
to at the land so they're trying to be
as comic-book accurate as possible with
the exception of moving this into
present day but of course I'll be doing
all kinds of videos for the series when
it gets here it's only going to be 8
episodes and I think most people have
pretty easy time finding it it's not on
cable it'll be on ABC in the United
States I don't know which channel it's
going to be on internationally but
they're shooting it on IMAX cameras the
first two episodes will actually screen
in IMAX theaters in August the series is
going to premiere in September so you'll
be able to watch all the episodes later
this year it's not like we're going to
have to wait a long time to get
but if you want to read the inhumans
comics you can pick up uncanny Inhumans
that's the ongoing title right now
they're in the middle of Inhumans vs.
x-men it's sort of a way for them to
reinvigorate both of the franchise's
they were both not doing so well sales
wise like Marvel wasn't doing a lot of
x-men stuff they weren't doing a lot of
inhuman stuff they've never been as
popular as the Avengers or the other big
characters at least since the late 90s
but there was a series just called
Inhumans by Paul Jenkins and jaitley
this sort of does their origin story and
it's a relatively self-contained 12
issue run but is there any bonus videos
you guys want me to do explainers for
characters just let me know in the
comments but there's going to be a whole
bunch of inhuman stuff rolling out later
this year they'll probably show off a
trailer at Comic Con so it all sounds
really cool so far but what's going to
be happening this weekend is that I'll
be doing more Logan videos just talking
about the future of those characters
doing Easter Egg videos talking about
Deadpool 2 and then I have Star Wars
Saturday now because it was Star Wars
Friday and then this dropped so whole
bunch of stuff coming really soon will
you wait for that you can click here for
my Logan review video and you can click
here to learn all about ego the Living
Planet thank you so much for watching
let's high-five I'll see you guys in the
next video